apple is releasing the m2 macbook pro
early and by the time you're watching
this video you could probably order it
or you're just a few hours away instead
of having to wait for next month like
they told us just a week ago so with
that many of you guys are asking is it
really worth buying the m2 macbook pro
or should you spend a bit more money and
buy the 14 inch m1 pro macbook pro
instead well today i'm gonna answer
exactly that and yes depending on what
you do for some the m2 macbook pro even
the base model will outperform the 14
inch for less money and because of what
apple did with the m2 macbook pro and
the newly released benchmarks that we
have we know almost everything about it
so this will be the most detailed
feature and quality comparison anywhere
on the internet to help you decide which
one to buy until of course we get our m2
models from apple and dive even deeper
with a ton of productivity tasks and
special tests that most people don't
want to spend time on so make sure to
click that subscribe button down below
to check out that video but this one
will help all of you guys who are trying
to decide which one they should order
right now the 13 inch m2 macbook pro
looks identical to the m1 macbook pro
heck it's pretty much identical to the
same one that came out in 2016.
apple decided to take the easy and more
profitable route and keep everything the
same other than a few software tricks
and replacing the m1 chip with m2 and
that not only frustrated many people
leading them to want to buy either the
redesigned macbook air or the 14 inch
macbook pro but that also gives me a bit
of concern about how the small single
fan will handle the now confirmed higher
clock speeds and more graphics course of
the m2 chip the 14 inch pro has the new
design that launched last fall with a
boxier slate type look that replaced the
previous high-end 13-inch now in some
ways it actually looks older and way
bigger but the 14 inch is actually
slightly thinner than the 13 it just
doesn't look that way because of all the
tapered sides but with that it is also
half a pound heavier that boxy design
allows not only for a larger internal
battery which will talk about real world
battery life in just a bit but also for
a much better cooling system as well the
intake slots are much larger and on the
back almost the whole section below the
hinge is for a hot air exhaust instead
of just two parts on the m2 13 inch
macbook with that the m2s exhaust are
partially blocked when the screen is
open whereas the new 14 inch has a
convertible design where the airflow
doesn't get blocked but instead it's
rerouted and can flow up in front of the
screen so no matter what even if your
laptop is on a blanket there are no
issues with cooling and thanks to the
newly released benchmark tests we know
that the m2 chip also uses more power
for both the gpu and the cpu and that
the previous m1 would sometimes throttle
in the macbook pro running on that
single fan loudly so we'll see how it
handles the m2 whereas the 2 000 14 inch
stayed silent pretty much all the time
even under heavy loads because of its
larger and dual fans along with the
better airflow design so if having a
cool and quiet system matters for you
keep that in mind the same thing goes
for speakers the 13 inch uses the same
ones from 2016 whereas the 14 has six
speakers with dual force canceling
woofers that sound much much better here
take a listen for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now even though we have a 900 microphone
setup the difference in real life is
even greater so if you care about having
great speakers the 14 inch is the way to
go now with that there is a massive
difference in webcam quality and not
only sharpness since the 14 inch uses a
1080p webcam instead of 720p in the 13
inch but the exposure and colors are way
better and then low light performance is
just incomparable i would just say apple
should have put a 1080p webcam in the m2
macbook pro getting back to the design
the 13-inch m2 macro pro gives you two
thunderbolt 3 ports one of which is used
for charging as well as a headphone jack
with the 14 inch apple gave its users
what they have been asking for for years
now and we have of course the same
headphone jack along with a dedicated
hdmi port and an sd card reader then we
have three thunderbolt 4 ports and a
dedicated magnetic magsafe charging port
which of course is convenient and it can
prevent damage this means that if you're
charging and transferring files from a
sd card reader or you're connected with
an hdmi adapter cable you are out of
ports on the 13-inch whereas the 14-inch
you still have three full-speed
thunderbolt ports available now yes you
can buy a dock or a cheaper dongle for
the 13-inch macbook pro and we covered
our favorite budget options in my
must-have macbook accessories video
which i'll link to down in the
description but it is nice to not need
any dongles or adapters and even if you
do buy one you'll still be limited to
only one external display at full
quality with the inch instead of three
with the 14 inch macbook pro now there
are some workarounds and there's some
expensive adapters like this anchor one
that can work but you will spend a lot
of money and compromising display
quality either way the 14 inch can also
fast charge to 50 in 30 minutes over
magsafe or usb type c if you have a
power source that is over 94 watts which
could be a usb type-c display or my
favorite power bank which i'll link down
in description below along with the 96
watt adapter that comes with the higher
spec models or is a 20 upgrade for the
base spec the 13 inch macbook pro will
take over an hour to reach 50
no matter what you have it connected to
now as far as how long they last the 13
inch is ahead due to its four efficiency
cores instead of two and the smaller and
much worse quality screen for video
playback you get 20 hours compared to 17
which isn't that big of a difference but
for web usage you get 17 hours compared
to 11 which does make a real world
difference of course this is from apple
using low brightness and very easy tests
that rely on the media engines and the
efficiency cores now in our extensive
testing we found that the m113 inch
macbook pro lasted three hours longer
than the 14 inch in mixed real world
usage and since the m2 uses about 10
more power for the cpu and 25 more power
for the graphics the real world battery
life will drop but will still be about
one to two hours ahead of the 14-inch
now another reason the 14-inch uses more
power is that larger notch display with
much slimmer bezels and with the much
smoother 120 hertz pro motion instead of
60 hertz now not only does it support a
billion colors compared to 16 million on
the 13 inch pro it also uses mini led
technology that lets it reach an insane
1600 nits of peak brightness and a crazy
high 1000 nit full screen sustained
compared to 500 on the 13 inch pro now
because of this we get super deep blacks
and very bright highlights so hdr movie
watching is amazing
and if you want to work with hdr video
or images you have to get the 14 inch
macbook pro the one downside is under
the most tough conditions you might see
some glow around small black bright
objects on pure black backgrounds but
this is very rare and in the same
situation the 13 inch macros blacks
would be great anyways and now on to
performance starting with the ssd speed
the 14 inch write speed is more than
twice as fast and the read is close to
twice as fast so you're getting much
better ssds and as far as cpu and
graphics performance we've already
gotten many results uploaded online and
we know that apple raised the power
usage and the clock speeds which allows
them to hit
1919 points for geekbench single core
which is the fastest on any laptop about
nine percent faster than the m1 pro for
multi-core m2 has a nice boost up to
8928
still slower than the 9884 and the base
m1 pro but it is now only 10 behind
whereas the m1 pro used to be 32 faster
than m1 in terms of graphics these two
extra cores really help and even though
the 14 core m1 pro is still more
powerful than the 10 core m2 if we do
the math apple is getting 2 983 points
out of each core compared to
2530 with the m1 pro proving the apple
is pushing more wattage to each core
which once again has me wondering about
heat and fan noise now as far as the
media engines this is one area where the
m2 is better the m1 did not support
prores hardware decoding and encoding
which only came with m1 pro and above
but apple surprisingly added that to the
m2 chip so a 1300 macbook pro will edit
prores better than most high-end windows
pcs but with that m2 has even faster
h.264 and h.265 hardware which now
supports ak
where m1 pro does not meaning that ak
videos will export faster with the m2 as
long as your graphics don't bottleneck
you and even if they do the m2 might
still be faster than the 14 core version
of the m1 pro doing the math that means
that the m2 can export 4k video at 120
frames per second now whereas the m1 pro
and the 14 inch only does this at 90
just like that one meaning for those of
you guys that work with standard 4k
video without a crazy amount of effects
which is most people on youtube the 13
inch m2 macbook pro will actually edit
video faster if both have 16 gigs of ram
now of course if you spend even more
money you can upgrade the processors and
the graphics in the 14 inch but most
people that are thinking of stretching
their budget to buy a 14 inch instead of
a 13 won't be just tacking on a ton of
extra money on top of that as far as
photo editing we don't know exactly how
fast it will be but based on our
previous testing and how much faster the
m2 is as well as the higher memory speed
and bandwidth i would estimate it to be
about two minutes or maybe slightly
under that for our standard photo test
so close to the m1 pro but not beating
it out if both machines have the same
amount of ram now of course the m2
allows you to get up to 24 gigs of ram
for 200 more than the 16 gigabyte option
whereas the 14 inch requires you to get
32 gigs for a 400 bump but i think that
if you're spending that much money on uh
for a 13 inch macbook pro to get you up
to 24 gigs it's not really worth it you
might as well go for the 14 inch so
overall even if you upgrade the m2 and
you get it close to the price of the 14
inch the 14 inch is still faster in most
ways now if you're getting the base
model m2 macbook pro that's a 700
upgrade unless you know that you need
something specifically from the 14 inch
i would not do it but instead i would
take a look at the m2 macbook air that
you can actually get for less money i
think that is also a better machine and
we actually have a detailed comparison
against that as well which you can check
out right over there go ahead and click
that circle above to subscribe to help
us reach our goal of one million
subscribers we would greatly appreciate
it thank you for watching this video
this one max and i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
you